Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 19th,
2013 2013.
Um,
I am still in New Orleans.
My last two days here in New Orleans.
I want to thank everyone.
Do you know what it
means to Miss New Orleans?
That's whereby baby goes,
okay.
She gets a Po boy pukes on a sidewalk down on Bourbon street with all the other
fucking whores
he up by Darpa.
Doopy Dbu.
You liked that?
That was a little low.
Started off with something,
I dunno,
some sort of basis street blues and I ended up with Clyde Mccoy's sugar blows
for all you out there who enjoy and unbelievably white man playing a muted
trumpet.
I highly recommend listening to Clyde Mccoy's sugar blues.
You know,
if people other than white people were running this country,
after that recording came out,
white people would be,
um,
banned from ever playing the trumpet again.
Now I'm sure there's probably some collide McCoy fans out there and I'm sure I'm
offending you right now,
but I don't give a shit.
The man is no longer with us,
unfortunately.
Can Not play that horn anymore.
Those of you are not going to have time to look it up.
The muted trumpet Song went something like that.
Wow.
It's literally that bad.
When I was six,
I thought it was good.
Oh fuck.
And you know,
I finally broke down.
I went down to Bourbon Street and uh,
it was 20 to five.
Okay.
On a Saturday,
20 to five.
What's funny in New Orleans is they have royal street runs parallel to Bourbon
Street.
It's one block,
I guess north of it.
I don't fucking know.
Just night and day.
Okay.
Stay on Royal Street.
It's a bunch of sane people.
Some really unbelievable street performance out here.
Man.
Musicianship is crazy.
But you know,
families,
you know,
fucking uh,
all these antique stores,
the gas lamp placed where they are,
the way they make the gas lamps,
you know,
in case you thought they made the gas lamp shit at some other place they may get
at the gas lamp place they got,
it's just a bunch of Nice stuff where you're like,
oh wow,
what a wonderful town.
Ah,
I'd work all this stuff to do.
Okay,
good.
Clean,
fun on Royal Street.
You go one block over over and you're on Bourbon Street and it is an absolute
shit show.
I saw a,
well she didn't take care of herself so she could have been anywhere from 26 to
about 59.
She had some hard miles people.
All right.
She was running with the,
she was down a couple of courts oil for at least two decades,
if you know what I mean.
You might need to work,
you know,
get a little valve job down on you.
Who had their lady.
Um,
anyways,
she's a,
I'm sitting drinking,
okay.
And uh,
I'm in this bar,
there's nobody else in it.
Everybody in the bar is dress like,
they're like coach from chairs,
then the band,
you know,
and they're playing,
I don't know what the fuck they were playing,
sort of jazzy sorta New Orleans Samad Shit.
And so I'm sitting there and I'm just,
you know,
it's open view.
I'm just watching people going down the street.
I took some video of it.
All right?
It was this white dude with great hair,
you know,
fucking dirty as hell.
Full head of fucking,
this guy could run for office with the head of hair that he had,
but instead he decided to mop the gutters with it for the last fucking,
I don't know,
since the 70s.
And he was out skipping around freaking people out.
He,
you know,
it's funny that guy had been drunk for so long.
When he would sit down,
when anybody would approach him,
he would immediately put his hands up like,
hey man,
I'm not fucking doing,
why you half on me?
He's just so used to being hassled,
mad that when somebody comes up to him or he's so used to people coming up to
him,
telling him that he needs to tone down his behavior,
that the second and anybody got in his peripheral,
he immediately put his hands up.
Hey,
you know,
just sitting here,
man.
Um,
he had his little bottle of booze.
Then there was this hilarious black dude,
direct and traffic,
um,
making most people laugh and driving control freaks out of their fucking minds.
So that was fun.
This is all like 20 to five in the afternoon.
Sun had even started to set and then across the street,
this woman,
I don't,
58 59 maybe early sixties.
She's with her guy and this other couple and she starts getting all fucking
loopy or whatever and she just,
uh,
she blew chow to bring back the old way.
We used to say puked back in the day.
She blew chow all over the fucking sidewalk.
And this is the funny thing,
all she did when she threw up was she just like,
it was like somebody said,
can you see your toes?
And she was like,
you know,
I don't think I've,
I've tried to see my toes in a long time.
She just looked,
just,
she just looked straight down and just fucking yakked
it kind of Rekesh shade off for belly and then hit the sidewalk show.
She was near the landmine,
but was,
was fine as long as she took a step back or if you went right or she went left
and she just fucking,
she went straight.
She took one step and did a Benny Hill fucking slip.
Not really.
She did like she sort of collapsed like Bambi and just landed in,
in our,
our own fucking puke.
Um,
and her friends sort of were comforting her letting her sit in our own pupils.
Fucking unreal.
Then meanwhile the other guy is skipping around with his bottle of booze.
Hey man,
leave me alone.
And uh,
so the guy put them in like a UFC show code,
which I don't even know if he knew the guy.
He just put him into it in a joking way and the drunk do with the great hair
immediately.
Just played along and we sticking his tongue out and I don't know what the fuck
was going on.
And then the black guy was still directed traffic am looking at,
my watch is fucking 20th,
five
on a Saturday.
And the thing is the people who are them who are an absolute fucking mess,
they should be antiquing the age that they were.
And all those stores that are really nice on Royal Street,
all of them were closing up.
That's how I ended up in a bar.
It was like,
why are you guys all closing up?
And they're like,
ah,
you know,
we close up around five gets a little crazy one block.
Oh,
it turns into such a shit show that they just,
they uh,
they just closed down,
um,
or whatever.
So anyways,
I've,
I've had,
despite that crazy story of Anna,
I'd have had a great time down here and I've just kind of becoming a saints fan.
I got to get out of here soon because we've kind of becoming a uh,
a saints fan.
I got all into the sentimental part of it,
of their,
their longtime announcer.
Of course,
I don't want to have his name in front of me here.
I'm going to,
I don't want to butcher this.
He did his last show.
Um,
his last show,
was he doing standup bill now?
He did his last broadcast saints.
Let me look this up here.
So I get this right and fuck all you guys down here in New Orleans giving me
shit right now and not from here.
Retires Bang A,
we go long time saints announcer retires.
Can I get a name?
Jerry roaming and a,
you got to listen to some clips of him on a,
on Youtube.
He's another one of those classic throwback guys.
Total homer.
It's awesome.
And uh,
I hope he doesn't always getting replaced by his son.
So he'll be a homer too.
I just hate when they go from a homer to just some guy.
Well you don't know where they're from and you just get some,
you know what the fuck I'm trying to say.
Anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody,
um,
oh,
people have been asking me,
you know,
send emails,
you and me,
what do I send it?
Bill at the MLM,
podcast.com.
That's where you send them in if you have any fucking questions is set and the
other and all that bullshit.
So,
um,
yeah,
there's,
I got two more days,
two more days on this movie that I'm doing down here.
I know.
Been dicking around saying that I'm,
I'm doing an episode of Glee.
Obviously you guys don't know that for those of you did look it up.
I'm doing a movie down here called black and white with Kevin Costner and
Octavia Spencer.
Um,
and it's been an unbelievable time.
Unbelievable shooting that whole time.
It's been amazing.
So,
uh,
I have this weird sort of,
I'm excited to get the fuck Outta here and I'm,
I'm
also going to be a little sad.
Been here for awhile.
Oh.
And also of course directed by my binder.
Um,
they all got great Boston names costs this Spencer binder.
so that,
I don't know when it's going to come up.
Probably going to come out next year.
So,
uh,
I don't know why I'm fucking hyping a movie that we haven't even finished
shooting yet,
but uh,
I guess it's what you have to do nowadays because there's 9,000 channels.
So look out for it.
I think it's going to be a great one.
There we go.
And onto the stories for this week.
A Romanian doctor.
Um,
did you guys see this story?
This is one of these stories I just don't believe is true.
Even though I retweeted it.
I refuse to believe that this is fucking true.
Says,
stressed out doctor cuts off man's Elf.
Patient's penis.
All right.
Yeah.
I don't know how to say the guy's name.
Nom.
See,
oh,
Mu 58,
what is with the 58 year olds this week,
if they're not puking on Bourbon Street,
that cutting off somebodies Dick.
Rarely does this have to do with the size of the moon in the sky.
The moon is minimally.
They always fucking talk about how that affects your goddamn mood.
The moon does it
and exactly.
How does that work?
I would love to just see a table full of scientists listened to this laughing
their asses off right now.
Wiping tears from their eyes unto their fucking,
I'm smart white coach.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
now [inaudible] 58 was operating on a man to correct a testicular mealth
malformation.
Yeah.
You see that?
This is a vanity thing.
His balls were working fine.
He just didn't like how one of them looked,
you know,
kind of like when a woman has one wonky teddy,
like once once focused and the other's the backup quarterback checking out the
chicks in the front row.
You know,
so I have a deli.
He had the same problem except it was his bowls.
So what he was,
he lost his temper trying to fix this guy's balls.
Okay.
Sweet.
Grabs a scalpel and he sliced off the guy's Dick.
I love this word here in front of an amazed nursing staff.
Not Horrified.
Yeah.
Not Nauseated.
Amazed.
How did he do that?
And he would,
would've thought that one of us try to stop them,
but by the time I realized what he was doing here,
you already did it.
Do you think we'll ever be that good at Umaine?
Evidently,
that's an amazing thing for a nurse to see in Romania.
They were amazed.
Um,
and then not to mention this,
after he cuts the Dickoff,
he then cuts it into three pieces.
Yeah.
For those of you mathematicians out there,
that's two cuts.
I,
I wonder if you just stab the scalpel in there,
into the table and then that was it.
Alright.
And then he stormed out of the operating theater at the pandery urology hospital
in Bucharest.
That's the capitol to of Romania.
So there's no excuse for this behavior.
This guy should be the best of the best.
He's working in the capital.
I could see if he was out in the sticks,
you know,
I don't know.
Wurster.
Um,
okay.
What the fuck was going through this guy's head?
Did he not have the right equipment?
The keep getting the malformed ball into shape and then it kept on mal forming
and you know,
like when your fucking computer keeps crashing,
that's basically what this guy did you ever get mad at your cell phone and he
just fucking throw it?
He did the,
the medical version of that and evidently that involves cutting off a dick.
Um,
so this,
it gets even weirder.
A Romanian court has ordered professor see Alma,
whatever his name to pay a hundred grand damages and 20 and $20,000 cost to the
victim.
Yeah,
whatever's costs.
Okay.
Did you still charge them for the operation?
Well,
you know,
we did kind of shape up,
what are your balls?
Tell you what that was going to be,
40 grand,
but we'll take 50% off and all the gods unique.
Um,
in this guy was a 36 year old build,
a 36 year old.
The trauma,
the gun,
this is what the guys,
now this is the hits.
This is underwhelming statement.
The trauma has left a deep mark both physically and psychologically.
It's hard for a man who wants to have sex.
Sex yet lacks the Oregon.
My wife is the best thing I have as just for this one worst fucking thing.
There's no way this is true.
Okay.
How do you,
how do you know this shit is true?
Even if you see it on,
I saw it on the news.
So what?
Yeah.
So what,
how do you,
how do you know what happened?
They look up to Susan.
Another one.
This was the one up in a new fileman,
right?
40 pythons found in Canada motel 10 days after two boys were killed by an escape
snake.
Did you see that story?
Like how do you,
how do you fucking know that that happened?
I'd let you were there.
Other than that,
I'm just sitting there and I'm listening to some woman talking and then they got
a picture of a snake over a fucking shoulder and then they cut to somebody
standing out in front of the house.
It's true,
Jennifer,
it's trill,
tragedy,
dead strike today in this great house.
If he could see that window air as well versus snake was and somehow,
I don't know how it went up the stairs.
I mean maybe they had those round ones,
you know,
the spiral staircase and it went up the stripper pole that's in the middle.
I have no idea.
But anyway,
somehow it managed to get up to the second floor,
had a eight,
not one but two.
They basically said that there was very abnormal for a snake for snake lovers.
He's been to Canadian brothers,
apparently squeezed to death by a 15 foot African python.
Uh,
they were typical children who enjoyed life to the maximum.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean there's six and four.
What's one of them looking through a fucking telescope already?
I guess it could be an advanced learning.
Everybody is typical at six.
And for that I missed my calling.
I maybe this is like,
this is what I should've done.
I should've written news articles.
This is how fucking dumb you can be.
The nursing staff was,
hey,
what's that word?
Uh,
just amazed.
Amazed,
amazed.
Yeah.
That sounds good.
What are you getting for lunch?
Um,
and spent the last days alive playing with animals on a farm.
A relative said Tuesday,
the boys were as sleepover and an apartment above a pet store when the snake
struck Canadian police said it's slithered Oh,
did it?
And it didn't walk into the room.
It's sluggards slithered through the top of its,
it's Florida ceiling cage.
Jesus Christ.
I don't have a whole connected to a ventilation system and dropped from the
living room ceiling when a pipe broke autopsies.
Oh my God.
It's terrible.
So then it was,
this guy says that this was not,
um,
said it was abnormal for a snake to go on a,
on a killing spree.
Yeah.
You know,
which I believe that,
right?
They just kind of,
they just take what they need.
They all eat just enough.
Okay.
You look it.
When's the last time you saw a fat snake?
I mean,
there were all muscle.
All right,
so this one,
I don't know what this fucking thinks
deal was.
Okay.
It was like thanksgiving.
It just fucking kept going.
But how am I really talking about a snake?
They killed two fucking little boys.
I'm sorry.
All right.
What am I going to do?
Make Fun of the Po boys in the Goddamn fucking paddle boat out there again?
Oh,
they're fucking paddle boats driving me nuts.
Fortunately it's out to see.
Can you be out to sea on a river?
What is an Eddie?
Does anybody know?
What is the difference between a C and an ocean?
That's the kind of thing like if,
if you're not a captain or you're not in the navy.
Okay.
I mean,
I bet half the people in the fucking Navy couldn't tell you the difference
between an eddy as see a Gulf.
Yeah.
Everything to me is the ocean.
Like the Gulf of Mexico.
To me,
that's the fucking ocean.
I'll be talking to me how old it's surrounded on three sides yet and what
fucking 9,000 miles in each direction.
I'm in the middle of the fucking ocean.
Okay.
Right.
The only reason why the great lakes aren't oceans to me is because they're not
salty.
I stick my face in them.
I don't golf.
I don't do that shit.
And you know that one that they have out there in California,
the salt and sea,
that's all salty.
That's the fucking ocean.
It's not a lake.
It's not a c that is the fucking ocean got left.
It got left behind like Willem Defoe and um,
in platoon.
You know,
I just found out all that out that thought,
that the whole,
that desert out there,
they used to be the bottom of an ocean.
I had no idea.
So wouldn't that mean
no,
that wouldn't mean that I was gonna say that.
This is fucking dinosaurs down there.
There's some sort of oil.
Do they have a drill in the desert foil?
Dude?
What the fuck you think you're Middle East?
He is.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
You haven't been there.
You don't even know what it looks like.
You just see it on the news like I do.
What does the Middle East to you?
Okay.
What is it?
Huh?
Our planes flying in there.
People throwing rocks at him.
That's your geography before you get on your fucking high horse,
dude,
I'm sorry.
I'm in this mood.
I am bored shitless out here.
Aye.
I'm done.
I've got two more days.
I want to bang this shit out and I want to get an a first fucking one smoking
and get the fuck out of here.
I've had it.
I need to go home.
I need a beat with my stuff.
All right.
I miss my stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
I really miss them.
I miss my pajamas.
I haven't seen my pajamas at a month.
Okay.
How long do you have pajamas before you lose the top?
You don't even know where the fuck it is.
You only wear the bottoms,
right?
Just walking around,
scratching your balls,
making that face.
When you look into the kick in the refrigerator and there's just nothing there
that looks edible anyway,
everything's work.
Um,
anyways,
let's do it.
Let's do a little,
a little advertising for the week here.
Um,
dollar shave club,
everybody,
there are so many things in the world that irritate me.
Raccoon hands.
I don't like to hit they,
I don't like the raccoon hats.
They creep me out.
The word expedite.
I don't like that word.
I don't even think it is a word.
Okay.
All right.
If it is a word,
it became a word from storage to saying it because the only fucking people I've
ever heard say it and uh,
what else?
Oh,
people will hold their nose before jumping into a pool.
You know?
Can you just breathe out?
You know,
can't you just do that?
How old are you?
Right.
Um,
anyways,
with all the,
so many things in the world that can irritate you,
why would you let your razors add to it?
That doesn't make any sense.
What I'm trying to say is stop milking your razor blade for the entire month.
You know,
digging up your face.
I know the brand name razors,
you're used to paying outrageous prices and exhausting those raises until they
start to look like a rusty code.
It soda.
Can I realize this?
Well,
it's time to let that go.
Stein to move on.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing quality blades to your door for just a few
bucks a month.
You never have to think about it again.
They send a pack every month just for a few bucks.
You can change your blades every week.
Trust me.
Your face will love you for it.
That's true.
I use it and you should.
To Join Dollar Shave Club,
shave time,
shave money,
you get it.
Go to dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] that's dollar shave club.com/
[inaudible] or click on the dollar shave banner,
a dollar Shave Club banner.
Sorry,
on the bottom of the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com all right,
Hulu plus everyone.
I'm sure you've tried hulu.com if you hadn't,
if you haven't done that,
I'm sure that's why you're friends aren't talking to you anymore.
All right,
but if he happened to hulu.com I want to tell you about Hulu plus.
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere streaming on your TV or go with it or you can put it on your smartphone
or your tablet.
Why stand in a line or ride a train and just stare at your feet before puking
and then slipping in it.
You could be watching your favorite shows on Hulu Plus Hulu plus is a great wage
way to binge watch your favorite shows.
Hulu plus has tons of episodes for great companies like SNL,
Co community,
modern family,
South Park,
family guy and thousands of other shows.
Hulu plus is only seven 99 a month.
Everybody that seven 99 for all the shows and movies you can watch catch up on
current shows,
binge on old favorite or catch.
Just catch a great movie.
Whatever you want to do.
He can do it all on Hulu plus people right now.
He could try Hulu plus for a couple of weeks free on me.
When you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu
plus banner or go to Hulu plus.com/bill please make sure you use Hulu plus.com
bill so you can get an extended free trial.
And so they know that we sent you all right.
Helps me keep the lights on here and gives you a better deal.
One more time for extended free trial,
Hulu plus.com um,
hey,
we only got one more.
I might as well knock it out.
The voice,
a voice.
Everybody.
If you're an entrepreneur and accustomed,
uh,
let me try that again.
Bilberry g boys take
to Poop,
poop,
poop.
[inaudible] voice.
If you're an entrepreneur,
sorry guys,
I'm sorry.
When out last night
he always take three
e voice.
If you are an entrepreneur and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're in a high rise window view,
fancy pants office or do you want them to know you're sitting in your underwear
with he voice?
You can create the appearance of an entire building,
sales,
customer support,
tech support,
you name it,
give your customers the royal treatment with he boys.
He voice will forward your business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are,
he voice,
we'll find you.
Don't have time to take a call.
It's routed to your voicemail and you can read it at your convenience as an
email.
He voice not only gives you an edge over competitors,
it takes away the edge the big companies have over you right now and now you can
try he voice for free for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and use the Promo Code Bill.
That's easy.
voice.com Promo Code Bill,
or just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on the full
email.
Ah,
the voice banner.
Sorry.
All right.
That's the advertising for this week.
That's always a great way to end the advertising.
Sorry,
I apologize.
I'm not qualified for the job.
Um,
all right.
What else did I want to talk about this week?
Uh,
if you guys been checking out what's going on over there in Egypt,
man,
it's just a goddamn tragedy over there.
Those people,
you know what a democracy is too.
It's too new over there.
You elected a guy.
It turns out you elected the wrong guy.
You didn't like him.
You just got to wait for the next election and then you vote the bum out.
You know,
you know,
fucking just demand the guy leaves.
You do that.
Here comes the army,
right?
He's sitting there with fucking rocks in a dream.
I don't know.
It doesn't work out too good.
Um,
all right.
This is a fucking disjointed podcasts I've ever heard.
One.
I swear to God sometimes I really wonder why you guys continue to listen.
Oh,
Bill,
stop fucking me.
Oh,
you know bill w why,
why,
why?
What are you going to be like?
That guy who threatens to kill himself and never does.
Just so he can hear so much.
People love him and the way you listen to that.
Oh Bill,
don't stop podcasting me.
Love your podcast and your red cunt.
All right,
follow up on salads.
Let's get into the,
uh,
the emails for the week.
Oh,
you know what I didn't finish last week was I started to say I was actually
rooting for a rod and people mentioned that I,
I forgot to say why.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno why it was something about everybody bowing and that just made me a,
it just,
yeah,
just the level with which people were booing the guy,
you know,
and I'm a complete look.
This is how I look at it.
I can't judge the dude.
The only way you could pull them like that as if lived a perfect life.
All right.
All that money on the fucking table.
C'Mon.
Complete piece of shit like me.
He think I'm not going to fucking do some roids to hang in the game.
Do you think if they made a steroid that allowed you to read advertising
smoothly?
That I wouldn't be on the juice right now just so I could stay in the podcasting
league for another couple of years too,
for the kids.
I don't have the feed.
Um,
there's,
I,
you know what it is.
I don't like how people,
they,
uh,
I don't think it's fair that they look at like entertainers and athletes the way
they do and start saying,
this is what's wrong with this country.
We blue,
blue,
blue.
They still going down like that and then they just fuck it.
Let bankers go.
If they,
if they gave just as much more shit to bankers and then they came on athletes
and entertainment,
it's like that.
I'd be like,
all right,
that makes sense.
That makes sense to me.
You don't,
I'm going to do,
I'm going to go,
I'm going to fucking start my own trading cards rather than tops like baseball
or football cards.
I'm going to start mine.
It's going to be banker cards so everybody knows what they look like and they're
fucking,
stats will be on the back.
All the horrific shit that they did.
And I dunno,
maybe they'd get booed when they're on the way to their lobster.
Fucking and crusted lunch when that be nice every once in a while.
So there you have it for some stupid reason.
I'm rooting for a Rod.
I want them to hit him a bunch of fucking home runs and a,
I dunno what after that.
Okay.
Just cause everybody,
I'm only a few people booed him.
I'd still be against them.
But the fact that everybody was just fucking trash and it was a couple of people
had sides but a some more on said the other day.
Well you know it's good.
I'll leave.
P Days really puts that pleat rose.
They get a perspective what it now.
No it doesn't.
Gambling is the worst fucking thing you can do.
It's worse than PDS.
It's worse than an individual cheating.
All right.
You're talking about when you start gambling,
you're talking about throwing the game.
Yeah.
Then it becomes wrestling.
Right.
And I'm not saying that on a certain level that you're,
you're up in the anti,
but the pds you definitely are.
But gambling is the worse.
The outcome of the game.
Okay.
CanNot be decided before the fucker gave starts.
You can't have people doing that shit.
All right.
You want to take some Gogo juice and maybe change the outcome.
I think that's half as bad.
Why is my voice,
you know,
when I was in a bar last night screaming over music,
um,
it's not as bad.
And for everybody who's going to send me a fucking email about
it@billatthempodcast.com I'm telling you right now,
I'm closed off to your opinions.
You can try and sway me,
okay?
But I don't want to fucking hear it.
Gambling on baseball,
it's the worst thing you can do.
That's why they have it over every,
every thing.
When you walk down the tunnel,
that's what they have.
Oh,
by the way,
don't go out there and throw the game.
This isn't wrestling.
All right?
Put on Jaqual Velvet.
Go out there and try.
All right,
sorry.
Follow
up on Salads.
People,
Bill,
I make salads for a living while eating vegetables from your grocery store is
better than nothing.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You're going to talk about pesticides and then kill me.
He goes,
you should urge your listeners to go to independent farm stands.
I'm from New England and they're everywhere.
Try smelling a peach this from a farm versus one from the grocery store.
This guy's 100% right.
He goes,
you should go to a farmer's market.
The one from the grocery store won't smell it all.
It's because they picked it too soon and lacks up to 75% of the nutrients.
Yeah.
That's why tomatoes tastes like shit.
And people when they make a [inaudible] salad,
they'll fucking put the Balsamic vinegarette on it to try and,
oh,
are you make a,
uh,
when you make your pizza sauce,
they always end up throwing,
you know,
whatever fucking third,
a cup of sugar,
depending on how much you fucking use it.
But that,
that's the natural sweetness that isn't in the tomato.
Because from what I've kind of read on a website,
maybe
like a,
hey,
maybe you can handle this fuck.
head.com.
I think I went to that and they were talking about tomatoes or anyways,
so once,
once you,
basically
the,
the fruit of the vegetable gets all,
it's all it's nutrients from the vine or the branch,
the tree,
whatever the fuck is hanging from.
Right.
So once you yanked it off,
it's all okay.
Uh,
I can't use that reference.
I wasn't talking about taking a baby out of a womb too early as disgusting cause
we're talking about eating something.
Alright.
No Jesus Christ.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
if you go down to your farmer's markets much better.
That's what he's trying to say.
But I've actually seen the thing where age,
they're starting to infiltrate the farmer's markets because those cons can just
not make enough money.
Um,
but anyways,
thank you for the followup.
I would have liked if he gave me a recipe for a couple of salads.
If you make sales for a living,
that would be great.
Help help the listeners out.
Give us a little variety.
Give a gift.
I want three here.
One to ease somebody in to the fact that they're reading salad.
If they went from eating a goat's head every God damn day.
And then the second one,
um,
I don't know,
make it down a medium sized one.
And then the last one is a few.
We'll just want to shoot your brains out and have energy of Superman.
All right.
How bout,
how bout,
how bout three salads like that?
That's my request,
sir.
Thank you.
Send it to the,
to bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
All right.
All right,
here we go.
Follow up from a lady.
Okay.
Hey Billy,
I'm a lady.
Just want to uh,
offer a piece of advice or referring to the guy on your last podcast who called
in about his ex girlfriend texting him after they had broken up.
Um,
she says,
I have actually been one of those country girls you were talking about and have
broken up with guys in the past.
My advice to guys listening out there is the absolute best thing you could do
when an x calls or texts you is to remain completely bored sounding on the
phone.
Oh,
completely bored standing on the phone,
never text or call them back.
Sound is distant and un and as uninterrupted as possible.
Um,
when talking to them,
guaranteed the x will never ever call again because it's humiliating.
That was my experience anyways.
Your advice was correct that you need to just cut the cancer out,
delete from cell phone,
unfriend,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Hope you read this out loud.
Okay?
Sometimes it helps to put a finger under each word.
When reading
she said just being cheeky.
Um,
God,
I hate that fucking word.
Are you being shaky?
Yeah.
All right.
So there's great advice from a lady.
There you go.
She says,
just sound completely as completely bored and uninterested as possible.
It's humiliating to them.
Yeah,
because you really,
you know what you're doing.
You're pouring water on the lightsaber basically.
Does that make any sense?
Well,
lightsaber it looks more like a dick.
What am I trying to say?
Was there anything that somebody used as a Jetta that kind of looked like a
fucking pot?
Okay.
That lit up that you could pour water on.
Was that electricity?
That's what I was thinking.
Do you pour water on and what would that do?
Would probably Zap your hand if he had a metal.
Fucking,
my reference is a fucking terrible this week.
You shutting off their,
uh,
I dunno.
Yeah.
Turn it off their pussy.
Gaslamp above their pussy.
You're just putting it out.
Um,
the best thing to do is you just fucking get away from them.
Are they going to make your life a living?
Hell?
That's what they do.
They don't Duke it out,
except for those broads on the UFC jab to the,
to the tit jab to the tit uppercut to the fucking areola.
These body blows up.
Brodo kick to the womb.
Oh,
right in the VJ j.
She's got to fucking hang a Fred the standing eight count.
All right.
Was he a virgin?
Dare belly their belt.
First of all,
I'd like to say I'm a huge fan from your hometown of a walk,
a Luca Maka Duca.
You are a comedian.
You are my comedian crush.
I absolutely love you.
While you've obviously never met me,
believe me,
I'm a piece of shit and up.
Difficult to live with,
so why don't you set your standards a little higher?
He says now to the problem,
I was celibate for almost two years.
I grew tired of it and decided to sleep with a guy I've liked for a little.
I'd like for a little,
but I didn't know him too well.
Let me start by saying,
honestly,
this isn't something I do ever,
but I needed to get laid.
It was a slutty thing to do now wasn't,
it was alright.
It wasn't,
he fucking have that urge.
Whatever you want,
how you did it,
fuck you going to do.
Um,
but oh well.
I was good long and I was good for long enough.
Anyways.
He's a little socially awkward and quiet,
which I initially thought was cute,
but found out there's a lot more awkwardness in them.
I don't know.
The date itself was awkward,
but I was Horny and he's a nice guy,
so I wanted to get,
so I wanted to get it in.
All right.
First it's not fucking around here.
Um,
he started by nestling his head in my breasts and rubbing his nose on them in
between and all around.
He did this also when I got on top of him,
but when he did it,
he,
he did something extremely strange.
He squeezed my breasts very rapidly,
almost as if to haunt them.
I laughed at first because I thought he was playing,
but he kept doing that.
And then he did the same thing to my ass.
Multiple
God,
he,
she says,
well endowed in both of those areas so I understand and playing with them.
But something was strange about it.
This is really fucking weird me out.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
Oh go,
go,
go.
Then beaches,
download Bogle,
Bobo,
Bobo.
Was he doing it like at the same time or was he like alternating with each
hands?
He should have been doing that while winking either.
I,
you know,
just completely freaking you on.
Occasionally sticking his tongue out and you'd go into some sort of fucking
epileptic seizure.
Anyway,
she said when he touched me anywhere else,
he would only use the palm of his hand.
At one point we were laying next to each other on the bed,
maybe just doesn't know what he's doing and I guess he remembered.
I said I liked my hair pulled,
so he randomly grabbed a fist full of my hair and he yanked it.
This sounds like somebody who can't dance trying to dance to something,
uptempo.
This is fucking horrific.
I feel horrible for this guy.
Like this is like,
this is such a bad performance.
This is like a first round draft pick bust like three games and you're like,
oh my God,
what did we just throw a million dollars at?
This is over.
Yeah,
give this guy a clipboard.
Um,
anyways,
she said we were not even having sex yet and it and it,
and it wasn't like he guided my head to his lap or anything.
What,
when we finally did have sex,
it lasted less than a minute.
And I'm not exaggerating when he told me he was about to finish,
I told him to get on top so we could have more control.
Okay.
But he put all of his body weight on me and was done in half a stroke.
Oh,
like
all in one.
All right.
He fucking threw the Hail Mary again.
I'm not exaggerating.
He went down on me to compensate and I'll spare you further.
But he knew nothing about what he was doing.
Yeah,
I kind of gathered that.
that was nice throughout this because I never thought,
because I never would want to give anyone a complex,
but when you fucking said where you live,
so I feel bad about this.
I want to have to uh,
have that bleeped out.
I'm going to bleep that out and I want to fucking blow up.
Anybody spun at 38 minutes in.
All right.
39 minutes.
Um,
I'll spare you the further details,
but he knew nothing about what he's doing.
I was nice throughout this because I never would want to give anyone a complex,
but dude,
what the fuck did I just fucking autistic man or a virgin?
He's 26 and he's a sweet guy.
I almost want to teach him,
but I don't want to insult him.
Any advice?
All right,
well first things first deal like the guy.
Okay.
The,
even like the guy.
Yeah.
Before you get involved in this,
the money pit here as far as fixer up houses goes.
MMM.
I Dunno from,
no,
I don't know if he would just trying to be funny.
But from the way you describe this,
you know,
there,
there has to be a jumping off point.
Okay?
Oh,
who knows?
Who knows?
Maybe.
I Dunno.
I don't fucking know.
26 years old,
I dunno.
And he's fucking grabbing your ass.
Like if you see somebody who knows how to make an Omelet really quick and can
fucking open them up eggs with one hand does like he's doing that with your
fucking titties in your ass.
It's just weird.
But you see,
all right,
I want to go with you like him because what can you do?
A Jesus cry though?
Where to start?
You didn't even mention him kissing you.
You know I,
I don't know.
I think this guy's fucking weird.
Okay.
The fuck was with the nose all around your titties.
I don't know what to tell you.
I got to give you advice here because this is the advice part.
Okay?
I almost want to teach them.
I don't want to insult him.
Any advice?
How the fuck do you go about that?
It's just such a fucking man.
You know?
Usually when you give somebody advice,
you know who's sensitive.
What you do is you compliment the things that they did well first and then you
ease into a,
they this could maybe use a little work here,
not saying you bed because you did this well,
just saying this over here,
maybe is there,
what,
did he do?
Anything?
Well,
how was he when he pulled his pants back up?
Was that pretty smooth?
Uh,
you know,
he gets ball stuck in the Zipper,
was able to not do that.
Maybe you could start with that.
MMM.
Oh Jesus,
isn't it?
So this is why women are so amazing.
The fact that she's actually willing to work with this,
she's going to try to make this work.
Don't,
I don't know.
I,
I guess I would try and figure out something that he did well and I would
compliment that and then I would just start chipping away at the mountain.
Okay.
I wouldn't try to bring the whole mountain down in one day,
but uh,
you know,
just know you,
you get,
you get a long fucking road ahead of you.
Jesus Christ.
He took two years off from sex and that you,
you know,
it sounds like you were having sex with like the first robot ever and it was
somebody like controlling of,
you know,
and they had an inability to,
to they have robot hands caress.
So when you know,
comments,
correct.
Caressing,
right mom,
hey mom.
Right,
right.
It was just,
it was meeting dough.
Ah,
Jesus.
Hey,
good luck with that.
I'm sorry I got to start sending DVDs to people who I just can't fucking come up
with anything.
I got,
I got nothing.
All right.
Nicknames though.
What is the best way to respond to a nickname that you hate?
I recently got one dude who was simple rhyme with my name.
Uh,
I didn't do anything stupid or conti to earn it.
It was funny at first,
but after a few months I find myself getting annoyed and angry when called by my
fee,
by this name.
Most people have moved on and stop calling me that.
However,
two or three people still greet me with it every chance they get.
How do I share this name without looking like a Douche and potentially making
things worse?
All right.
First of all,
you don't let on how much it bugs you and then what you do is you come back
giving him the fucking Howard,
sir.
All right?
You got to come back with the anti aircraft.
You got to look.
You got to come up with nicknames for these fucking people.
Just start with one guy.
Don't do all three at once.
They'll know what you're up to.
Just pick one guy.
All right?
We're going to slowly whack these gripes.
The one,
one by one,
get this dude,
that guy.
Then you get mo green through his fucking glasses and we're done.
Um,
they got a big nose.
Something physically fucked up about their face.
They got man tits.
They'll get it real quick.
They call calling you something.
EA.
What?
What's up there?
Flabby tits or man,
ted.
So just something,
something about them that you know that they hate about themselves.
Hopefully something that's unfixable.
You know,
unless they went under the knife and God knows what they'll do it in Romania.
Right.
That's what I would do.
But the first thing you do it do not let on that it bugs you.
So when they call you,
whatever they call,
you,
just sort of laugh,
big smile,
and then you just fucking hit him with you.
Give him the old right there,
Fred.
All right,
that'll shut them up.
Hopefully that's what I would do.
Or You just quit.
Your job
fails.
You get the fuck out of there.
Change your name.
Uh,
the worst thing you want to do is go stop
that.
Then that just,
it's fucking,
it's over.
It's over.
Um,
then you have live action.
Twitter in your fucking life.
Getting trashed.
24,
seven live action,
Facebook or whatever.
Alright.
Embarrassing.
Um,
Bill,
I can't spell for shit.
Um,
so let,
so let it go before you start hitching.
I,
you know what,
go fuck yourself.
I got to sit here and I got to undo all of this
embarrassing.
He spells that wrong.
Embara embar sing.
He spelled e embarrassing.
He spelt n.
E m.
See people.
I'm not the only one dumb.
I'm just going to read this.
How he wrote it.
I can't spell for Shit,
so let,
so let it go before you start hitching.
Funny story,
wanted to share it with capital.
Why a,
I promise this as true.
An older man I know had gotten a vasectomy.
He spelt it right with the,
with this new age laser,
laser treatment.
They do.
It's an in and out kind of treatment.
Now,
was asked to come back a week or two later to make sure everything held up the
way it was supposed to.
When he got there,
he told the lady behind the desk why,
why he was there and she handed him a cup and told them they needed a sample in
pointing to the bathroom.
Oh No.
Did she mean Tj's or Wiz waiting room,
which was filled with people.
FYI.
He went in and 15 minutes later came out with a cup of mango and proceeded to
walk past the people in place,
the Cup on her desk.
She slowly looked up at him and told him in front of everyone that she only
needed a urine test.
God,
Oh my God.
I really hope that's true.
How do you fucking,
well,
she only gave him a cup.
The fuck is he supposed to do?
They hand you a cup.
That means that means to rub one out.
Right.
They hand you,
they give you that plastic bottle.
That means just supposed to paint it.
Oh,
they do that shit all the time.
Yeah.
At doctor's offices.
Like they just forget cause they're there and it doesn't mean shit and they will
just yell out,
you know,
anything.
You just come walking in,
hey doctor so and so.
Hey are you it did it clear up?
They still get the one Claire up and they immediately think he's got something
on his balls.
Man.
Is it a contagious?
Um,
that's fucking hilarious.
Okay.
God Damn it.
This fucking embarrassing.
I wonder what kind of a bathroom it was.
Did it have multiple toilets and people coming in?
They're pissing and he's over there.
He hit,
they'd make a noise cause the doctor because he feels the doctor said to do it
that it's like somehow,
okay,
oh by the way,
this is sort of a hacky shit joke and I don't want to do it on stage,
but I'm sick of people complaining about people blowing out the bathroom.
Okay.
Oh my God,
this guy came and he fucking blew out the bathtub.
Oh,
maybe next time you should take a shit in the kitchen.
You know?
That's what,
that's what it's for.
It's a fee.
It's designed so you can sit down and take a shit.
You want them to go outside in the yard.
It's like being mad bacon smells like Bacon.
Jesus,
what the fuck did you eat?
I Dunno.
Something healthy.
And then it stayed with me for a couple of fucking days and went to nine miles
of intestinal,
you know,
clinging on other shit.
Then what do,
what is your shit smell like?
Yeah.
I've never understood that.
Like when I go into a bathroom and in,
somebody blew it out.
I fucking makes me laugh.
Just a face you're making try not to smell it.
It's fucking hilarious.
Well that,
and when people get mad that babies cry on planes.
When babies start crying on planes,
I just start laughing because I just feel like they're expressing everything
that I'm feeling,
but I'm not socially allowed.
I would love to just start crying.
I don't want to be on a fucking plane.
The second I say expedite the boarding practice,
I just want to start fucking crying
anyways.
X Won't move out.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
He is a fucking situation.
Hey Bill,
huge fan of yours.
Loved that.
Loved the Monday morning podcast.
I will keep this short as I know you don't like to read.
I like to read.
I'm just not good at it.
I'm like someone who likes to play drums but stinks at it.
Um,
I recently bought a house and asked my girlfriend of three years to move in with
me.
We have been living together for about six months and then we broke up.
She was the worst.
All of my friends and families,
they're not like her and she wouldn't let me hang out with friends.
No,
no,
no.
Let's,
let's put that in proper perspective.
It's not that she wouldn't let you hang out with friends.
She asked you not to and you agreed to it.
All right.
You have,
you have the power,
sir.
Anyways,
she wouldn't let me hang out with my friends or watch any games with French ever
capitol all call and caps.
I tried to get her to hang out with,
with her friends,
but she was so insecure.
She never trusted me even after three years of loyalty.
Anyways,
we broke up about three weeks ago.
No one cheated,
lied,
or stole from one another.
It was just time to move on.
However,
she keeps saying she's going to move out but doesn't.
Um,
I don't want to throw her out on the street,
but what do I do?
But,
but I do want her out as,
it's just not healthy for me to keep living with her.
Also,
she refuses to pay any bills or help with the mortgage.
What's a fair amount of time to give her before I just go legal honor?
Well,
hindsight's 2020.
You should have told her from day one when she had to be out by.
MMM.
The fact that she's not paying any bills or anything like that.
I mean it's just like I would just hit her with the little two pronged attack
here.
I would just go,
listen.
Uh,
we broke up three.
how would you dip into this fucking hell.
Gives a fuck.
Just I was going to save you like,
Hey,
you know,
how's the house a apartment hunting coming.
I would just go right at it.
I would just say,
listen,
it's been three weeks and I really don't think it's healthy for us to be around
each other.
Um,
when do you think you're going to be Outta here by and let her answer em and
Hawk and then just say,
listen,
I will,
I need you to be out by this date because I have to get somebody else in here to
help me with the mortgage.
All right.
You're not paying any bills or helping with the mortgage.
So this isn't fair to me.
So you need to be out of here and her name is and on the mortgage.
So worst case scenario,
one day she goes to work,
you call in sick,
pack up all his shit and fucking put it out on the front line.
You're out.
And what she kind of say,
what's she going to do?
Call the fucking cops.
You don't have to go legal on our,
get the fuck outta here.
This is my house.
We broke up.
Get out,
out you out.
Get Out.
Okay.
Um,
I don't actually,
I don't know if she has any.
Okay.
Anything legal?
I have no idea.
I don't fucking know,
but that's what I would do.
I would give her a definitive date.
You need to be out by this time.
And uh,
I dunno
what else?
I don't know what else I'd do.
My,
my,
uh,
there's,
it's still,
we get it.
We're on the Mississippi with the fucking horn.
I get it.
MMM.
Just make up some shit too.
I need you out by the 15th of next month.
Uh,
you know my uncle,
the,
my second uncle lives in Tennessee.
He's got tuberculosis.
He's moving in and a,
he's bringing that machine with themselves.
You gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
I know.
It was kind of a short one.
Oh Jesus.
52 minutes.
I can't do that to you.
Okay.
Well I could technically I could if I want it to,
if I wanted to be a dick about it.
Um,
okay.
I just got it.
I got a bunch of scenes tomorrow.
I got to learn all my fucking lines.
That's why I'm doing this thing early.
Hey,
you gotta you gotta admit when I'm shooting something to fucking podcast comes
out on time.
This is going to be three weeks in a row with this thing being out like Sunday
night in most areas.
So,
um,
how bout a little props?
You know,
Pablo,
for once you don't give me shit.
You actually give me a little bit of a,
Oh fuck.
I gotta be somewhere in 40 minutes.
God Damn it.
All right,
this is an x to show one.
I'm,
I apologize.
I'll try and make it up with the longer one over the last couple of weeks.
So they,
they,
they have been long.
Um,
all right.
I got to get moving here.
Fucking Christ.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Now that the show's over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu Plus who plus let you binge
on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smartphone,
or tablet support.
This podcast.
Also in get an extended free trial of Hulu plus.
When you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com Click on the Hulu plus
banner or go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/bill,
thank you for listening.
Oh,
everybody in Scotland,
the Glasgow date is on sale.
I have the link up on bill bird.com and um,
Monday today when,
I guess when you're listening to this,
we added a second show at the beacon theater in,
um,
in New York City,
uh,
soil.
Be adding a link for that when I get the time.
I think the entire European date is up there.
All those tickets are on sale.
Um,
what else went on?
Sale San Jose,
Seattle,
uh,
Philly
and I think DC.
I think all of those are on sale.
So I got a bunch of shows out there that are all on sale.
Oh,
people of Scotland.
It would be great if you showed up by the way,
because we had to really fight with them to find,
find some sort of venue because they didn't think anybody was going to show up
when I was out there.
So I'm at some venue that has a lower area and an upper area.
Um,
so I dunno.
Let's see if we can get a couple of people up in the upper deck too,
if you can.
All right.
Just call every cut,
you know,
and come on down.
All right.
I have at least a new hour and a half since the last time I was fucking there
and it'd be great if you came down.
Saw it.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Don't take any shit.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll talk to you next Monday.